all right this is crazy after living
here for about a year we're finally
getting settled in so I'm building this
bike rack right here which has been in
storage for 2 years I bought it at our
last house cuz we're going to start
taking way more bike rides cuz at that
time I think Tao was like four and Tao
was riding his own bike and we're like
cool we're going to do all these trips
and then that's when we found out our
house went up in Valley like crazy if
you guys watch that Vlog we go into the
details of how we're able to come up
quite a bit why we sold and here are
some tips that you can adopt into your
own real estate and property investment
strategy but because of that we have to
pack up our bags start showing the house
so you have to keep everything really
tidy almost make the house look like no
one lives there we did that for about 6
months to show the house and then we
moved here and once we moved here um we
obviously have not unpacked very much
cuz cuz we're waiting for the backyard
to get done waiting for our side yard to
get done so we can move the gym and make
that the storage and by the way yes we
planted a big ass tree this just came in
this week really excited about this
because as you can see all the houses in
this neighborhood look very very young
right because of the the trees they all
look like kind of like this one right
here so which is why when we're planning
the landscaping for this house I was
like put a big old mature tree so it
looks cozy like been here for a while
and it's nice you could actually even
hear the leaves
rustle but
anyways the backyard side yard front
yard is finally getting done so we're
able to move things around now and I'm
like okay cool now I can get to the
garage so the first thing I want to get
to is building this bike rack but it was
just crazy seeing the date on the
receipt on the boxes I was I can't
believe I bought something and I didn't
open it for 2 years have any of you guys
ever done that like you buy something
and then something happens and it's just
like stored somewhere and then you're
like holy I could have bought this
two years later anyways I got to build
this
now this thing looks so
complicated but there's not that many
parts there's only like one 2 three 4
five but because the parts are all weird
shaped it's throwing me off and the
instructions have no instructions or no
words just pictures so I'm trying to
figure out what this gray piece is right
here and I'm like what is that is that
this
nope oh I think it might be this oh
right there it is right those two dots
those two dots okay so we got to install
this
probably like
here yes that's the tray okay I get it
that's the tray for probably either the
back or front tire and the other other
thing is the back and front tire Jesus
I'm so glad I'm talking to you guys cuz
as I was looking at I was like I don't
get this but as I'm speaking out loud
I'm like okay I'm getting it bam done
Dy this actually looks super cool this
looks like I'm about to go on some crazy
ass Adventure but I'm not I'm just going
to get things maintained cuz these bad
boys have been sitting out see all this
dust there's rust on the Chain right
here it's been sitting out and about for
a long
time cuz we've been moving and stuff so
we haven't been able to get settled in
um M be is going to start riding bikes
for Fitness which is why we're getting
the road bike tuned up and for me you
know me I'm more of like a brute I like
off-road so I'm uh tuning up the
off-road bike cuz we could only fit two
bikes on this rack so the next time
around I I'll switch it I'll do her
mountain bike although I don't think M
be is going to ride her mountain bike
very much and I don't think I'm going to
ride my road bike very much but it'll be
good to have all four of them maintained
and then put them in the garage so that
they are not sunbaked and fully dusted
and is this going to ruin the seat okay
there we
go and everything could be in working
order cuz these bikes are pretty
expensive but ready to rock and
roll
meanwhile the monkey man has been
patiently waiting for me to swim so
before I drop off the bikes I'm going to
come swim with him and see what this guy
is up
to hey monkey man hey you got your
goggles on the cool ones o la
Juna don't disappear don't disappear no
no no no no no no oh where'd he go no
where'd he go mama mama where'd he
go he's upside down
there he is I love your sunglasses
goggles they're cool but did you like my
handstand I did with one hand oh you
only did with one hand
whoa you need to put on your I like I
like your widow's peak yeah I did I did
that I
did WOW with one hand what about your
widow's peak who who needs to answer for
that do you want me to do it that again
who answers for that Mama who got it for
his widow's peak guys want me do the
handstand again sure
guys
good job guys I you want me to do it
with a one finger can you do with one
finger mhm oh I can't
tell so it's unfortunately my time of
the month right now um and I just have
the worst stomach ache cramps so I'm
just sitting here reading my book I'm on
my Kindle cuz I watch these studs swim I
was here for a little bit but somehow
the dogs took it over and I was like all
right forget it so I'm going to sit but
the cutest stuff has been happening
right now ta is getting more
more it's getting more and more
comfortable with
swimming I to the pl and back here so to
the plant swim back here are you ready
yeah
no thumbs down today no thumbs down good
job what does thumbs down mean so our
little agreement is I want to learn how
to breathe on his own between strokes
but anytime he can't because once you
come over here his feet can't touch the
ground anymore like he can't push up off
the ground as soon as he gives me a
thumbs down I go and I grab him that way
he he feels safe and right now he swam
all the way over without needing
help
good job Mom my feet did not touch the
ground try to swim take a breath and
swim again okay and then if you need
help give me the thumbs down
ready you didn't take a breath in the
middle yes I did you did no no you
didn't don't be a liar no I don't think
you
did that's a breath right there that was
a toe touch toe tou breath though try to
take a breath without a toe touch using
your arms use a rainbow but instead of
this way down okay how do use so this is
a regular Rainbow this is a down
rainbowz like this yeah it'll push you
out of the water try
it did you breathe I saw you breathe did
you touch the ground he did he he
breathe I don't know if he touched the
ground I don't think he did actually
good job job good job hoodies okay let's
go
back dropping off the
bikes so one thing I really love about
Las Vegas Summerland in particular is
that it's a very bike friendly City so
Summerland has bike paths all over the
place and there's pasos that go in
between all the communities cuz their
goal is is one they want to make it
where all kids can walk home from school
without ever having to cross the street
so you can always stay on the same side
of the street cut through a Paso through
a community and then get to another
community and another Community until
you get home so that part's pretty cool
but the other thing that I really
noticed about General uh Vegas in
general is there are bike shops in every
Sub City so like if you're from La there
might only be like one major one in
Santa Monica maybe one major one in the
east LA area that serves the entire San
Gabriel Valley maybe one or two in the
OC and that is like in a 2 3 hour radius
there might be like five bike shops
maybe even a 5H hour radius with traffic
in Vegas because they're so bike
friendly and every sub city like I
believe in Summerland there's already
two Centennial Hills there's a couple
Southwest there's a couple um the Lakes
there's a couple and all of these are
like 10 minutes apart so this part's
really really cool where all I have to
do is just literally drive like 5
minutes to where I used to live cuz on
the other side of Summerland is where
the two bike shops are at so that's when
I'm going to go drop off the bike so for
those of you guys who have been
following um our like moving Journey our
Vegas journey and there's a lot of you
guys out there cuz you guys straight up
come up to me when I see you guys in
Vegas like yo I moved to Vegas cuz of
you or I've been following your
footsteps um this another good thing
about Vegas if this is something that
you're really interested in just dropped
off my bike at Las Vegas Cyclery you
could actually see the big sign from uh
the freeway over there and originally I
thought I had to drop off taica bike too
but they actually gave me the tool so I
could just crank the pedals myself um
which will be good cuz you want them
riding ASAP the other two bikes I think
they're in pretty bad shape so it's
going to take about a week for them to
fix it to get it up and running so when
you enter into this place you're going
to be like ho this is
gargantuan if you can't already tell by
how many bikes that I've walk past me on
this side it is a huge Store look at
that three
stories of bikes on just this side
another three stories over there bikes
all in storage over there there's
rentals and then on that side where it
says service is where I just dropped off
my bikes so this place is freaking
incredible um most of the bikes in here
are pretty legit so you'll see like the
common names like specialized
[Music]
canondale um some pretty expensive bikes
like oh my God look at this one this
one's like 4GS so for those of you guys
that aren't used to the mountain bike
game from my friends that are really
really into it they tell me it's pretty
you could even spend like 10 G's on a
bike and that would be like not the best
of the best but that's like like
entering into that top tier so the
average bike I think is going to be
anywhere between two to 5 grand brand
new so if you want to get into mountain
biking you can get a used one for like
one or two grand but it is an expensive
hobby when I first heard that I was like
10 jez isn't that the amount of a
motorcycle but the amount of like
delicacy that these instruments need to
handle or the intricacies of how they're
built is insane oh here's another one of
those big Brands Santa
Cruz it's like beautiful beautiful
pieces of work of
art all right so I dropped off my bike
now going to head home oh look how cute
this is cute little riding riding
Jersey and just like that about to be
back home in 5 minutes and so back on
like the moving topic and again doesn't
always have to be Vegas you know you
could do your research I'm sure there's
a lot of really cool cities out there
that have a lot to offer but um even
running erand is one of my favorite
things about Vegas and what people from
the big city I think should really look
into like not to blame it on this but I
feel like one of the biggest reasons for
my procrastination while living in La
was just because every errand took 2
hours like if you want to go to the dry
cleaners it's going to take 2 hours
because of traffic and once you get to
the dry cleaners you know there's
already going to be a line you want to
go to the Post Office UPS like every
single thing took 2 hours so you end up
going I'll do that later I'll do that
later cuz it's going to push your day
back so much that you end up having an
entire pile up of stuff that takes like
almost 2
weeks just to get caught back up to
speed versus in Vegas like I literally
dropped off my bike and I'm going to be
back home in under 20 minutes and
because of that I feel like I'm so much
more productive and I can feel this like
um feeling of anytime I have something
that I need to do I let do it right now
let's take care of it because I know
it's capable and I can actually do it so
that's something that of value too where
I think most people complain about La
San Francisco New York traffic
that's just I think one of the many
components one of the other things is
how much less productive are you in your
life because of that cuz everything has
a domino effect right like when you're
15 minutes late you're not really 15
minutes late when you're 15 minutes late
you get there 15 minutes late then you
need 15 minutes to settle down then you
have you need another extra 15 minutes
to really get engaged then you might
need another 15 minutes before you need
to turn in whatever deliverables your
job requires you to do so 15 minutes
turns into an hour and I realize I have
that exact same domino effect in my life
where some an errand might take like 10
minutes here turn to 30 minutes there
then that ends up taking half a day I
look back at my day and I literally did
two things you know so um one of my
favorite things is having moved out here
and I'm sure any of the other uh less
populated cities like um or States like
Utah Idaho Texas or whatever you
probably just have so much more
bandwidth think clearly on the stuff
that's actually
important okay monkey what time is
it D my hair Dy my hair dye my hair Dy
my hair let's go let's go dye my hair
let's
go so what's the whole deal with dyeing
your hair young man I when I'm get a
kangaroo card I can dye my hair and I
and I am a kangaroo card
oh so for those of you guys that don't
know Tiger has been doing really really
good in school and in his classroom
every single time he does something good
he gets more and more stars and you
start ranking up almost like a jiujitsu
belt system so you start off at what
turtle so you start off at Turtle did
really good P then you got promoted to
penguin and you get five stars at each
animal do you guys want to see my turtle
C in my oh yeah got show show them the
turtle C it's on the fridge that's
true
right there yep right here so you start
off as a turtle and then when you do
five really good things you get five and
then you move up to penguin and then you
do another five and then you get
kangaroo and then Panda and then cheetah
and I believe you can get all the way to
the
top I in you You' been doing awesome now
took the Brant ants but now now you
change it to the end into instead of a
real instead of the Falcon a gold Falcon
wo no that now that's be that's before
the Falcon I see so yeah so he wanted to
dye his hair and I told him I was like
you know what if you get kangaroo we get
to dye your hair and he earned it so
we're going to dye his hair
today okay so I don't know exactly what
Ty is visioning is what do you want to
dye how much on your hair like that just
the tip just the front that's called the
bangs right here so I have is it like
this no pretend there's no color pretend
it's just yellow pretend it's not red
like that no or do you want it like like
this more on the bottom so not the top
just a little bit on the bottom no okay
so which one what are we what are we
doing to you I don't know do you want me
just to do what I think is
cool no
sure oh yeah you can put this D my hand
right here okay just D the front I don't
know do I have to wait a little bit a
little bit Yeah cuz you have to wait for
the hair to change colors so it takes a
little bit you want me to do it yeah so
kind of like that like this guy just a
little bit like that yeah okay that guy
looks weird he looks weird but yeah but
that's the same idea you but that's what
you want right just a little bit like
that yeah okay like this guy yeah oh
there's a little streak like that okay
don't know what I'm
doing let's do
it no not there here okay okay so you
want to right down the middle it's not
on one side or the other yeah cuz I
think it'd be better if it was just
either this side or this side not the
middle the middle would be kind of funny
I would just do the side like that oh
mama so what do you want you can have
whatever you want Mama's just giving you
some suggestes in the middle in the
middle okay oh
boy he's a ooh
you say you I okay so do you need some
like hair pins or hair clips or no I'm
good I already have all of it
professional so let me see if I
can hold your hair back oh Mama's
prepared dang that's a lot of
hair oh I could tell mama's been has
done this before okay I'm thinking
maybe something like
that back back back back back like that
what do you think Papa you're holding
your fingers this this yeah okay can you
hold this wait wait wait wait don't do
anything okay wait so oh my God your is
so short can you hold this for me this
right here me yes you gu yeah wait let
go don't let go right pinch it just
pinch it and don't let go yep good job
okay let's see I didn't realize your
hair was so short even mama can I tell
you something yeah am I old enough to D
my hair what do you mean I mean we're
doing it right now like am I old enough
yes well the it doesn't matter the age
doesn't matter it matters what your
parents think oh I didn't know are you
asking if it's legal let ital is it is
it like like if you'll go to jail no
it's
like it's comp I don't know okay don't
say it's complicated cuz it ain't that
complicated boy wait wait wait wait
don't don't move too
much yeah don't move too much cuz I have
to figure out how we're going to do
this what's the foil for Mama I don't
know so that it activates faster I have
no don't move too much okay monkey
because I monkey don't move too much cuz
then all the bangs are going to fall out
yeah your hair is very tiny and very
veryy Cy I don't know how long I'm
supposed to leave it in here
for that look like
blonde well it's science baby just know
that
science they told me to use half but I
can't even see where the half mark is oh
eyeball it yeah just eyeball it eyeball
it yep is that blonde mhm that's that's
on in there yeah well it's purple but
it's going to make it blonde how I think
that's about half BR my hair is not my
hair is not going to be purple my hair
is nowhere going to it's not this is we
bought the blonde
one did
you they say to add this protect this
hair or cany uh in the mix yeah oh we
can I mix it if not then I just fed up
making any poop on my pants pancakes
mama is making pancakes right there eat
some it was was all the Dy hair stuff
don't move your hair too much oh yeah
don't you're moving too much you're
moving too much yeah she's making
Uber hair she's making Uber pancake with
all the dye ingredients for my hair
don't touch your hair baby he's making
Uber Pancakes on my
head monkey do you know what I'm telling
you not to touch your hair m
are you listening to me or I'm going to
stop are we listening okay perfect I'm
telling you not to TI touch your hair
because of the clips your hair's so
small and fine it's going to fall out of
the clip cuz this clip's Made for More
older
hair okay is going to say say what
happened to your hair I said I died it
over the weekend and then I and I said
I'm going to put you in the face all
your friends are going to ask you what
happened no no I said my cousins and oh
your cousins I see are you oh man e it
smells bad why does it smell like that e
this hair this hair well buy there my
cat in my head like this is so
much are you exit so real quick okay
ready y mom don't move baby move okay
don't
move God I want to put it close to his
scalp because as someone that has bleach
their hair yeah it's going to start
itching it well I can burn it yeah it
can burn my what my hair yes don't move
okay don't
move I'm not moving
okay I cannot you're totally moving I
can not touching my nose holy Mo I can f
out on my hair yeah don't don't move
even if your nose itches or if your face
itches don't scratch it okay this is
like the worst D job ever my nose is
itching but I'm doing this don't why are
your head moving towards this way you
were here before dude yeah so yeah face
that way don't move at all
okay that does not bother M move my nose
it good job yeah if your nose itches
just do that good job good job
monkey all right that's as far as up the
route I'm going hey mama is is that
blonde or purple there blonde don't move
don't don't cuz when you talk you're
moving okay well yeah have my
that's all I'm going to do for now
you're not getting any more than that if
it comes out jacked
up I'm
sorry I think going to come out awesome
I'll give my
hair okay so I've had this in his hair
jeez Louise for about an hour and like
10 minutes yeah 10 minutes so far we can
see that it's working
we're almost at the Finish Line
baby we're almost there cutie
patootie wait how many more minutes
until I don't know I don't know how many
more minutes it just depends on how fast
your hair process or like how quickly
your hair gets
light this is my bed all right so we're
going to see if this is blonde enough
for the gentlemen blonde on here you can
see it okay so I'm going to take it off
slowly excuse
me let me see there's this this like
it's like I'm getting a tattoo boat W so
it's
like that what do you think leave it
there keep going leave it like that I
like it it looks good it looks like a
like that you sure yeah it looks good
but just brush all this quite a heat
off you brush the Cola with the he off
okay so I'm going to wash your hair
here
are you excited yeah I thought to have
blonde hair I mean it could go blonder
but I think you give up right I think it
took a really long time for a sixy old
took for n it took for an hour and 10
minutes an hour and 10 minutes okay lay
down on your they probably gave you a
gentle one they know you're a little
baby a baby one not like in a bad way
but you're young yeah not like a little
be yeah cuz we went to the store if you
saw watched the Vlog yesterday and they
recommended us which ones to get and
they probably saw that was for like
little kids so they're like oh we
probably need something
gentle gentle for the
baby ooh I blonde that looks pretty cool
though I think you're going to like
it it was getting there if you would
have waited a little bit more but it's
it's pretty blond though it's like mine
a little
bit what hurts what hurts my hand okay
wait so just go take a shower then cuz
the edge right there I think yeah go
take a shower then okay I need to get up
you're not letting me get up
go that's Prett
cool it's it's
clean all right monkey stand up
straight show me the
hair remember it used to be all um all
brown and yeah but now it's Bond it's
blonde baby you look good dude you see
myself in the Mir pajamas your pajamas
on what do we do we like what we
see you're a
maniac I'm glad you like
it there's my boy with this cool hair
looks really cool and your cool
jamas that's
awesome this is crazy I was one of those
parents where I was like I need to
preserve my kids innocence as much as
possible and I was one of those parents
that was like no Mohawks no dying hair
until they're at least
15 but he earned it and if he earned it
and I gave him my word we have to keep
it and honestly when I made that packed
with
them I didn't think he was going to be
able to do it he like can I dye my hair
I was like yeah dye your hair when you
get kangaroo cuz he was like two animals
behind and he did it so got to eat my
words I'm proud that he earned it thank
you guys for watching
us thank you for uh watching us do a
Monumental thing in his little life and
we'll see you guys next time right
Mia